funny not paid for computer that has a
March price of $2,500 I'm gonna write
that down $2,500 if a 5% discount is
allowed paying cash they're doing this
right if you agree to pay cash we'll
give you a bit of a discount right 5%
disc a now you will notice like this pay
less pay cash business it tends to
happen for things like this Computers
there are hundreds and thousands of
dollars right that's why you know the
kinds of things these guys sell are all
sort of the hundreds of dollars usually
right this is not practically gonna
happen for these little things because
it's kind of like well the difference is
kind of small right whereas for here it
could be more substantial so you'll see
this scenario all the time some price
some agreed-upon discount sometimes the
discount is not a percentage
what alternative might you get it might
just be a cashback like I'll just give
you 50 bucks cash back this is uh this
is just an example in fact you'll see
ads that say is in time okay so either
be a flat melt or it'll be some kind of
percentage okay you need to pay
attention to the question and have a
thing about what they're asking let's
read by the amount paid the amount paid
okay so after the discount gets applied
how should we have purchases to differ
ways to do it okay and I'll show you
both and I'll let you decide which one
you prefer they're both equal you can
work out what the discount is right it's
five percent what's five percent as a
decimal it's it's point I five isn't it
good point uh fine so work out how much
the discount is right I should have said
discount
well this is five over 100 right that's
if you've checked out of your cap and
that would give you plan five yeah well
I want to work out as a proportion of
the original price excuse me so yeah you
can see when you are you can do it
mentally or you can check it on your
calculator you should get $125 as the
discount okay so that's how much you
were supposed to pay this is how
off right sir about pay is equal to the
total key regional minus the discount
that's all simple so when you subtract
it I think you end up with 375 dollars
of it okay so there's approach one you
work out what the discount is and then
you subtract it from the original note
okay there's a quicker way it's a little
bit more mentally tricky but I'll let
you decide which one you like okay
it's that off we're here at the discount
and then it's an unpaid separately I can
just go straight to this amount paid
I'll show you how okay this is my second
method I can say that well if you took
off five percent how much is left over
as a percentage ninety five percent is
what you're actually paying right so I
can say zero point nine five on the
whole map that's the ninety five percent
that's how much you pay right throught
the discount that's what's left after
the discount that you can chuck in your
calculator and if we've done our numbers
right you'll get back to 375 just like
you did before
so which method do you prefer the second
method shot up second method sure but
you've got to work out this no boss you
got to do that so this this is a bit
longer but at least it's kind of a bit
maybe you might find it clear up okay
yeah that's this that's exactly
regardless though I mean you got to
remember right and I keep on banging on
this drum I'm even sicker but you cannot
just do them in your head you must show
right it's gonna be it'll be two bucks
for this question right and if you just
write down that you get one cuz right
but you ain't get 2 because you haven't
show me where you got from right you
haven't shown that you didn't copy it
for the person next thing okay so does
that make sense okay now I just want you
to quickly cast your eyes down the page
for me I have a look at some of the
different kinds of questions that they
ask okay have a look let's go down to a
little further sorry a little further
back let's look at five look at five
with me plasma screen television marked
price of the step four thousand four
hundred and ninety okay the television
is discounted to four thousand three
hundred that's not bad yeah so you can
see the discount that's happened right
how much has been chopped off a hundred
knots good but then the question asks
something very different to this right
it says find the percentage discount
given so they want us to answer this you
see if they're asking a different kind
of things same scenario right how would
you work it out okay I'm gonna do it
exactly in the in Reverse right so you
guys just told me the discount right is
a hundred and ninety dollars so how do I
work out this as a percentage of it says
percentage of the original yeah yeah
okay I'm gonna take this one hundred
ninety right so here's the discount the
percentage discount is you take that one
ninety and you divide by something what
are you gonna divide by it'll be the
original now like so okay
now let's actually get our calculators
out and do that cuz we get a decimal and
I think they wanted to one decimal place
yep okay so I've got over four to three
bla bla bla bla
okay now read carefully they say find
the percentage discount correct to one
decimal place this is not a percentage
it's decimal so how do I make it a
percentage I multiply by 100 ok so this
is going to become four point two three
bla bla bla percent okay you see what
the difference is between these two
lines I multiply by a hundred to move
the decimal point but you want the
percentage so know how many disappoints
there one what just the one
and whenever you approximate you should
say what level you approximate what
level accuracy you approximated so you
can see is the same situation right
there's some discount that happen but
they gave you slightly different
information and so they asked you a
slightly different question okay